welcome to the ddps seminar everyone
before we introduce our invited speaker
let's go over some rules and Logistics
uh first of all please mute yourself
during the talk but if you have
questions you can unmute and ask
questions or use chat room to post your
questions so that we can address them in
Q&A session at the end second today's
ddps seminar is open to external
external audiences
uh therefore no classified discussion is
allowed so please watch out and finally
The Talk today will be recorded and
uploaded in our YouTube channel that's
about it now let me briefly introduce
our speaker today it is an honor to host
Elizabeth Quan who is an uh assistant
professor at Georgia Tech jointly
pointed in the school of aerospace
engineering and the School of
computational Science and Engineering
her inter disciplinary research develops
new computational methods to enable
engineering design and decision making
for complex systems with special
expertise in motor reduction scientific
machine learning and multifidelity
methods recent Awards include a 2024 Air
Force young investigator award and a
2023 Hans Fisher visiting fellowship at
the Technical University of Munich prior
to joining Georgia Tech she was a v kman
instructor at Caltech in the department
of computing and mathematical Sciences
she earned her SB SM and PhD degrees
from MIT today Elizabeth uh will talk
about multifidelity linear reg
regression for scientific machine
learning from scar data um I'm sure
she's going to give a wonderful talk so
please um have a high expectation but
before I pass the button to Elizabeth
let me ask one
question um I happen to know that um the
you the one sport you um regularly do
like once a week is the rock climbing um
I'm sure um a lot of people are already
familiar with with rock climbing among
the audiences but some are not so if you
can briefly introduce why you are so
into the rock climbing and you know
advertise rock climbing to them oh
goodness okay well if you haven't tried
rock climbing it is an Olympic sport and
uh the the the men's and women's Olympic
uh events are going to be next week I
think so you should look up the schedule
and and watch because it's pretty cool
to watch and that will also be my pitch
for why you should do it because I think
it's it's a nice sport for uh for
watching because when you go to the gym
you can you can try to climb and then
when you are tired and don't feel like
actively climbing yourself it can be
pretty fun to watch other people like
try to do the climbs um so I think it's
it's a it's a nice Pastime nice you can
utilize your time um in maximum
enjoyment yes awesome okay well floor is
yours Elizabeth all right so yeah thank
you for the invitation Yu uh to speak in
this seminar and I'm very pleased today
to present uh some recent work uh that
has been submitted uh came back from
review and we've resubmitted the
revision so fingers crossed that it will
be accepted for publication um and so
this is Joint work with honor Bon chod
who is a research scientist at un Austin
um and with my student dang Kong at
Georgia Tech and his student VES Cella
at UT
Austin uh so before I start I want to
say that um I typically like to take
questions throughout the talk so I will
try to pause in a couple places to see
if there are questions um and I'll also
ask uh Yu to help me monitor the chat
and just interrupt if if there's like a
clarifying question um I just think
talks work better if I can address
things along the way rather than saying
saving everything to the end and I've
you know planned the talk so that there
should be time for that
okay all right so the motivation for
this work as well as most of my work is
to support decision making in in
engineering and science um and when we
think about the decisions that we might
want to make a lot of times they rely on
what I will call a many query
computation so that includes things like
optimization uncertainty quantification
and control tasks so in optimization you
might have to query a model at every
step of a gradient-based iterative
method um in uncertainty quantification
you would be querying a model for um
every sample of say like a mon Carlo
like uncertainty quantification
computation and in control computations
you're quering the model um basically
you know at every second say in real
time to understand like what the next
control input should
be so traditional numerical simulations
that um come rprise most of our you know
traditional models are based on physics
um they're often high-dimensional
because they result from discretizing a
continuous uh governing equation on a
high dimensional computational me mesh
and that makes them generally too
expensive for this many query setting um
so these you know you're not going to be
solving these traditional
high-dimensional simulations you know in
real time sa for control or you can't
afford to do that many samples in
uncertainty
quantification so there's a real need um
for efficient you know and when I say
efficient I'm thinking like Fast uh so
computationally efficient and cheap
surrogate models to enable
decisionmaking so I think uh everybody
would probably agree that there's been a
lot of interest in machine learning
methods for surrogate modeling for
Engineering Systems um they've shown a
lot of
Promise
uh part partially through um some very
visible successes in other domains that
were traditionally seen as extremely
challenging so in computer vision and
natural language processing and and say
playing playing the game of Go um so
they've seen some real practical
successes and in addition to those
practical successes there are some
theoretical guarantees of of what I call
the expressive power of these of these
machine learning models so I'm thinking
in particularly about neural networks um
for which there are a lot of theoretical
guarantees that say like there is a
neural network of some shape and size
and form with some parameters that can
match like you know sort of any complex
nonlinear function like perfectly
essentially um but there's a significant
gap between that theory and Engineering
practice um and and that's because of
like basically what I was saying like
there is a neural network that can match
things perfectly it's just we don't know
a lot about like what the neural network
is like what its architecture is what
its parameter should be and so because
there's that gap between the theory and
the practice um there's a real lack of
trust I think for using these machine
learned models for engineering design
where you have some consequences that
impact that have like um you know high
costs both in terms of dollars but also
in terms of like potentially human
safety and so that's um a significant
barrier to the widespread adoption of
machine learning type methods in
engineering so to address that um one
might ask what is the reason that we
have trust in traditional numerical
simulations and
I would say that some of the reasons for
Trust In traditional numerical
simulations are that they're based in
physics which is something that we sort
of understand to be true so there's a
strong Foundation additionally we make
some really explicit and transparent
modeling assumptions in physics based
simulations so for example like if
you're going to simulate a fluid flow
with Oiler versus Navia Stokes like you
know that you're making an assumption in
Oiler equations that like the viscus
effects are
negligible um and that helps you
understand you know both when to trust
the simulations as well as when we don't
and in addition we have you know many
decades of numerical analysis that help
us understand the errors in these
discretized uh these like sort of
discretized pte
models so then we ask okay so in machine
learning or in statistical learning like
where do we get trust from
and uh I would in in sort of many of
these applications trust comes from Big
Data like the idea that you have so much
data that like you've kind of like seen
everything there is to see and and you
can really represent like that reality
quite
accurately okay so to be more
mathematically specific about what that
trust means I'm going to say okay we're
going to consider an input random
variable
Z and an output random variable y1 um
and y1 is some function F1 of
z uh and in the setting that I'm
considering I I really think of F1 as
being an expensive computational model
although you could think think of it as
as also perhaps being a physical
experiment but like let's just think of
it as a as a expensive computational
model so maybe this is something you'd
run on a super computer to get like the
output y of
Z and so the the surrogate modeling
problem from data is then to say okay
let's suppose that um fat is a
parameterized model with parameters beta
um and so I can choose some parameters
beta and then I have some input and then
I can give it my input variable Z and it
will predict outputs so the machine
learning task is then to find the best
parameters of that model so I want to
find the beta star that minimize um you
know this is a standard law so this is
in this case we're minimizing the square
of the error of the surrogate model um
and notice like we have an expectation
here so that's sort of like over the
joint distribution of the input and
output
data and because often we cannot easily
compute these expectations exactly the
standard thing then is to approximate
this from uh from data so now I suppose
I have input and output pairs um so like
I have capital N of them and so then
I've got Z being the inputs and then y i
being the outputs and so then I instead
of minimizing the exact expectations
we'll try to find the beta that um
minimize the empirical uh mean square
error so this setup I think is um has
become quite widespread and maybe
familiar all right so this is the
problem that is being solved in machine
learning
generally and essentially uh when I say
trust comes from Big Data mathematically
we're saying if that n is large enough
then this empirical mean square error
minimization well approximates this true
um mean square error minimization and so
if n is large enough then we trust that
the training performance is going to be
represented of what we call the test
performance so you know how we would do
on data that's not in on inputs that are
not in this training
set but in engineering settings n is
often small uh because each because each
of these yi1 data points comes from
evaluating that expensive
model and so we're often pretty far from
the setting in which we might say like
one could implicitly trust that
minimizing this error is representative
minimizing that error
overall and so the main idea of today's
talk is to address that lack of trust
due to small to small n or scarce data
by combining our limited expensive High
Fidelity data um with some greater
volumes of Cheaper low Fidelity
data um in order to address the the
small data Challenge and when I say
small data I'm really talking about that
small High Fidelity
data and so what I'm going to present
today is a new method um for
multifidelity linear regression so
acknowledging that linear regression
models are not as general as the neural
networks that I was motivating the talk
with but seeing this as kind of a step
towards U more General machine learning
models and in that linear regression
setting we're going to develop a new
method that's based on multifidelity at
control variants I'll explain what those
are um I'll present some bias and
variance analysis that help us
understand the accuracy um and
robustness of the of the models that we
learn from the multifidelity data and
then I have some numerical results that
uh demonstrate the sort of potential for
this multifidelity method to really
address these uh small data training
challenges so um I will pause right here
and just see if there were any questions
so far about like the notation the setup
um or anything
else I I don't see questions in chat
yet no
yeah it's um a pedagogical technique
I've learned to give a long pause in
case people formulate
questions okay well then I will jump
right into the first part of the talk
okay so I'm going to talk about
multifidelity control variant methods
okay so control varats are um a
technique or you know a family of
methods that actually arise from Monta
Carlo uh estimation of you know
statistics and the goal is to reduce the
variance of Monta Carlo
estimators so I'm going to set aside the
machine learning problem for now and
just think about like a standard Mont
Carlo estimate of like the output mean
so if I wanted to estimate the mean of
F1 of my random variable Z and I had n
samples of the inut Z then I could have
standard montra Carlo estimator is just
the sample mean of the
outputs and we know that this estimator
is unbiased so that the expectation of
this estimator is the expectation of the
is the true mean and that the variance
scales with
1/n and so if n is large then you know
this variance is quite small and so we
we think that the estimator we would say
the estimator has a low standard error
and then if n is very small then the
this variance could be quite large and
so this this estimator could have quite
a high standard eror so the goal of
control variance is to reduce the
variance of the estimator and the way we
do that is um we introduce like another
random variable so like let's just I'll
tell you what it is in a second but like
suppose that we have another random
variable W and it's correlated with the
outputs so it's you know maybe think of
it as an approximation so it's well
correlated with the outputs but and
suppose for now that we know what the
mean of that random variable is so we
like have some exact expression for the
mean of
w then this formula defines the control
VAR estimator so we've got mu hat and I
use CV to say this is the control VAR
estimator so we have this this first
term which is kind of the standard
original estimator and then we add a
second term which is a correction um and
that correction is basically the true
mean U minus the sample mean
of of of the W's okay and so the key
here is that these wi I are correlated
with these F1 of z
i um okay so this estimator has some
nice properties the first one is that
this control VAR estimator does not
introduce bias and that's because in
expectation like the expectation of w is
muw right so so that term just goes away
in
expectation um so that's nice and and
Alpha I should say is is some kind of
scaling coefficient I'll talk about it
more later but just think of it as a
constant for
now um the
second uh property I guess that we want
to analyze is the variance of this of
this control VAR estimator which uh is
related to the standard error of the
estimator and so I can can you know give
an expression for the variance of the
estimator just by expanding uh the sort
of co-variance definition of variance
and this is what I get in terms of um
Alpha so you see there's you know kind
of here's the variance of the first term
like here's the variance of the second
term and then here's kind of the sort of
cross that cross
term and you can minimize this
expression with respect to Alpha and
find an alpha star which minimizes the
overall variance of this estimator um
and that Alpha star is basic is given by
this expression so it's the co-variance
of the model with with your W and
divided by the variance of w so if I now
stick that Alpha star in into this
expression um this is what I get okay so
with the optimal Alpha star you'll see
that the variance of the control VAR
estimator is the variance of the
original Mont car estimator minus
something
positive or not negative uh and so
essentially the takeaway is that the
higher the correlation between F1 and W
the greater the variance reduction and
that makes I think some intuitive
sense Elizabeth yeah uh there's are some
questions do you want to take
it all right the first question is from
Kevin we need to know the exact mean and
the same number of samples are yeah are
used for w um yeah so we will end up
estimating the mean of w in fact I just
introduced it with the exact mean just
to get the idea across um and I will
talk a little bit more about the number
of samples of w but yeah I'm introducing
it with the same number of samples here
because it's just a bit simpler to not
have to have a lot of different letters
running around but we can relax that it
can be kind of there are different
sampling strategies all right sure and
the second question from uh duchant is's
asking are you ignoring The Intercept uh
term in the linear regression you know
general form is y = to MX plus C I see
you use the Y is equal to MX function
um
[Music]
uh in my numerical experiments I do
indeed have a an intercept so we allow
kind of a constant like you know one of
The Columns of the linear regression
Matrix is a bunch of ones um although I
don't I don't remember having that on a
slide yet all right
yeah thank you for the
questions all right so yeah um so this
is the main idea of control variant um
basically the higher the correlation
between W and F1 of Z you know the the
greater your variance
reduction and so multifidelity control
variant methods um are based on this
idea where we use lower Fidelity models
to Define that W um and so now I'm going
to say suppose I have some function F2
so think of this is maybe a coarser grid
than F1 or maybe you know some
simplifying assumptions are made
relative to F1 so that this runs
faster uh then this is the way I Define
the approximate control VAR and so to uh
Kevin's question like notice here now I
have replaced the exact mean with a
sample mean um and what I'm showing you
is is really the sampling strategy
that's based on what like some people
would say is the is the multifidelity
Mont Carlo method and then there's kind
of variant of this where you can have
you know different different numbers of
samples for each of these things um but
basically I'm saying that F2 is cheap so
I can afford many more samples of F2
than I can of F1 so this is kind of a
high sample approximation of the mean of
F2 so this instead of knowing the mean
of w exactly I'm approximating it with
with a lot of
samples um and I can easily generalize
this to many other low Fidelity models
um just by um adding you know additional
terms uh so for like the F3 term you
would have something like this for the
F4 term you'd have something like this
and there are several variations on this
theme um so the what I'm using in this
talk is um from this multifidelity Mont
Carlo paper which is a 2016 paper by
Benjamin payer ster and
collaborators um but uh Alex gordetsky
at Michigan um has done a lot of work to
generalize that and so that would be um
this work would would really kind of
allow n and M here to really vary in in
in more General
ways and um another variant is is known
as ml blue or multi-level best linear
unbiased estimators by um Dan shad and
and Elizabeth Olman um and that would
allow sort of even more General
structures like you would have sort of
different model groupings just to give
you a flavor of what exists um but these
latter two are a little bit more
complicated I think just in in terms of
the notation in particular so I'm
sticking with um multifidelity mon car
just to introduce the main
idea okay so um so I've introduced the
main control VAR idea and now I'm saying
okay I'm using low Fidelity models to
define the control variance and so those
low Fidelity models are being used to
generate correlated samples that are
going to help me reduce the variance of
my Monte Carlo estimator that's kind of
the punch
line um are there
questions all right so yeah this is just
kind of highlighting again what I was
saying so this is n expensive samples
and N is not very large from The High
Fidelity model and now I have lots of
Cheaper samples from the low Fidelity
model they're used to compute this
correction um in this 2016 paper
Benjamin Pariser shows that like the
multifidelity Mont Carlo estimator has
lower variance than the Mont Carlo
estimator of equivalent cost so like
there's kind of a constraint there
saying like Okay I'm trading off some of
my High Fidelity samples to get low
Fidelity
samples under certain technical
conditions which I will summarize here
by saying if the high and low Fidelity
models are sufficiently well correlated
and if the ratio of costs between models
is sufficiently high
um and the detailed conditions are in
that 2016 paper um additionally in that
paper they look at the influence of what
you might think of as hyperparameters of
the method so like you know what's the
best Alpha what are the best M and N in
this sampling structure and uh
essentially you can formulate an
optimization problem to say like what is
the alpha n and M that minimize the
variance of the mfmc estimator and uh
there's an analytical solution to that
problem and the the analytical solution
then depends on second order statistics
um of the models so Sigma being the
standard deviation of fub1 and F2 and
row being the Pearson correlation
coefficient so the second order
correlation
coefficient um because in many settings
those statistics are not exactly known
um the standard practice then is to use
a small number of pilot samples to
estimate those statistics and then you
get an estimate of the optimal alpha n
and M that you would then use um to
figure out the number of
like the NM and Alpha to to implement
this
estimator
okay um I see a question do I understand
correctly one needs M plus M samples of
FS2
um in multifidelity MRA Carlo actually
these are nested samples so it's m total
and then these n are the first n of
those M um but in some of the general
variants that I um mentioned uh things
are a little bit bit different but yeah
you need a lot more samples of of F2
than of F1 in
general all right so that's the sort of
background of multi mon Carlo and so
what I want to explain now is how we use
this for multifidelity um linear
regression okay so back to our linear
regression
problem um I have the input random
variable Z output random variable y1 and
where y1 is related to Z through this
High Fidelity model which is
expensive um so now I restrict to this
linear regression setting so I'm going
to say let X denote features of the
input okay and so this is where like I
could have a constant feature to allow
an intercept right um and you know so X
could be like polinomial features they
could be forier features they could be
um features you know chosen from some
Physics informed library but whatever
they are um I'm going to have a linear
combination of those features determine
my output so this is my model class um
so beta are my linear regression
coefficients and so now um just oh just
going back one okay so this is my uh
linear regression task basically
minimize uh this expected
error all right so this linear
regression problem is very well
understood so its solution um is given
by this formula so just the expectation
of XX X transpose inverse times the
expectation of x * y so just note this
is a square Matrix and this is a vector
so um so I'm going to
just note those Expectations by cxx and
cxy because like this is a covariance
matrix and this is in sense like the
covariance of the inputs with the output
and just remind folks um that if X and Y
are centered so if they have mean zero
then these are these covariances and
then the optimal beta star satisfies
this interpretation of the um residual
of the model being orthogonal to the
features so the standard way we
approximate this solution because you
know this obviously has expect exact
expectations is to say okay now given
data pairs you know um and data pairs of
inputs and outputs I will then
approximate these covariance matrices um
with uh the sample so these are sample
covariances
uh and then my Beta hat uh or beta and
uh I forget what I used oops sorry okay
uh then my approximation is is just
given by like inverting this sample
covariance multiplying it by this other
sample covariance okay so that's
standard um but I'm actually not going
to use the standard approximation um and
and the main reason for that is that
this is actually not an unbiased
estimator of beta star and that's
because cxx n here is unbiased for
estimating cxx but then once you invert
it like the inverse of the unbiased
estimator is not an unbiased estimator
for the inverse and for reasons that
will become clear I care very much about
it being unbiased so I'm going to do a
modified approximation of a linear
regression
solution um where instead I'm just going
to assume that I have cxx exactly right
um the justification for that is to say
well the expensive part of getting data
is really getting y1 right like every
output requires that I evaluate this
expensive model but in theory I could
get lots of inputs for free and
basically have so many input samples
that I could assume that I have a good
very good or exact estimator of cxx
because that only depends on the
features and not on the output of the
model and the other main reason like I
said is because this is now unbiased um
this beta has unbiased estimator for
beta star and that's going to be
important for us in in our multifidelity
model uh any questions about this
setup um ask um if F1 and F2 have to
share an input domain yes like so far
we've just kind of assumed that they
have the same inputs uh if they don't
have the same inputs uh you'll need to
do more
research
yeah but that is an interesting case
that of course we're aware of and and
thinking about how to
handle
yep okay so that's the High Fidelity
linear regression setup and so um having
chosen the parameters using that uh n
High Fidelity data estimator we Define a
trained model using those those
parameters um and now if I think about
for a given input Z like what is the
variance of the model predictions so fat
like um the variance depending on what
the data are um then in fact that
variance can be related to the
co-variance of these beta hat ends so of
those uh parameter
estimates uh which is what this says so
the variance in model predictions comes
from variance in the parameter estimates
and the variance in parameter estimates
comes from variance in these like cxy
estimates and so if we have a small n we
would have high variance in the cxy
estimates and therefore High variance in
these beta n estimates and therefore
High variance in the learn model
predictions and so that really kind of
kills your robustness like thinking like
training on this small data set versus
that small data set might lead to very
high like changes in the model
predictions so the main idea of
multifidelity um linear regression in
this paper is that we're going to use
multifidelity control variat to reduce
the variance of the cxy estimate which
is then going to lower the variance of
the betas which is going to lower the
variance of the predictions which is
going to improve the Learned model
robustness
okay so that's what's on this slide
basically I'm saying I'm defining a
multifidelity estimator of
cxy um using this m multi montra Cara
form so it's similar form to what's
before I mean those sums have gone away
because the sums are kind of being
written as these Matrix Vector products
but you have this like M sample estimate
minus this n sample estimate so you
recognize that form something that is
different is that this is a
d-dimensional vector that is being
estimated so whereas Alpha was a like a
scalar coefficient before here I've now
place that with an a which is a matrix
coefficient so you can think of as kind
of like a
gain um just s that and so with this
estimator this multifidelity estimator
of cxy then I have a multifidelity
estimator of beta that which gives me a
multifidelity learned model that uses
those parameter estimates so this is
kind of the main idea of the whole
paper all right so what I want to talk
about next is some of the analysis we're
able to do of this approach um are there
any questions before I jump to that
part
right
okay okay so the first um key result is
that this multi fideli linear regression
estimator is
unbiased so that was our estimator and
so the first claim I'll make is that um
the expectation of this estimator is the
expectation of X y1 which appears in the
you know the true formulation for or in
the true formula for Bas star and that's
un uh biased uh I'll get to that
question in a second that's unbiased for
the same reason as multif Mar Carlo
basically an expectation these two terms
are going to cancel because they're
estimates for the same statistic just
with a different number of
samples um because uh our estimator beta
hat MF is um linear in cat MF then in
fact where our multifidelity parameter
estimated for beta is unbiased with
respect to the true optimal parameter um
it's followed from linearity and then
finally that means our predictions are
also unbiased so that also follows from
linearity of the model and the
parameters and this is significant and
and it's basically saying that by
introducing this low Fidelity data like
we're not changing the bias of the
estimator so in that sense the low
Fidelity estimator does not have a
corrupting
influence uh on on the learning even
though we had
um like even though we added this low
Fidelity data um Jazelle I'm going to
defer that question until I talk about a
which will happen in like two
slides um are there any questions about
this unbiased bit
okay all right so the next thing I want
to talk about is the error because um
you know obviously the error of a model
sort of depends not only on the bias but
also on the variance um so let's talk
about what what is the variance of this
multifidelity estimator so um remember I
was trying to estimate X
y1 like that's kind of what cxy is
trying to the mean of xy1 is what cxy is
trying to estimate so I'm going to
Define a function G which is just like f
multiplied by the features so what I'm
trying to do essentially is estimate
like do a multifid estimate of the mean
of this function G now and so this is
the sort of High Fidelity function G and
then I've got some correction terms
based on the low Fidelity functions
G and so I can write an expression for
the variance um of this estimator in
terms of uh co-variances of G's so like
you see that like so um just as a
reminder G maps to like a d dimensional
Vector where D is the number of features
and so I can Define these gamma like
Gamma 1 one and Gamma 22 and Gamma one2
as being the covariance of like the high
fidelity with itself covariance of the
low Fidelity with itself and like cross
covariance
terms and so we see that the variance of
the multifidelity estimator definitely
depends on what this Matrix a is okay
and so that um you know starting to
answer J's question you know makes you
wonder okay what's the best
a um so just as a reminder when I was
just estimating scalar means like the
alpha which was a a scalar coefficient
had an optimal form uh that was the
coari of the f one and F2 divid by the
variance of
FS2 and so similarly we can show that to
minimize the trace of the co-variance of
this you know Vector estimator
um the optimal a star that would
minimize that trace the covariance um is
Gamma 1 2/ by gamma 2 like basic divided
by but yeah like gamma 22 inverse so it
has the same form and so you know I mean
that you know kind of gives you some
confidence that maybe I did my proof
correctly um and and yeah does reduce to
this and the like the Matrix optimal
thing does reduce to the scalar optimal
thing
um so that would be the optimal way to
choose star to minimize the variance of
the
estimator all right so we have a theorem
basically saying okay with with the
gamas defined the way I've defined them
um this choice is optimal in the sense
that it minimizes the trace of the
covariance of this multi estimator so it
also minimizes the trace of the
co-variance of the parameter estimates
and it therefore minimizes the variance
of the model predictions like you know
conditioned on the input
okay um so practical considerations so I
mentioned that for you know standard
multifid M Carlo just for scaler mean
estimation we have to estimate these
second order statistics of the models to
get the alpha star and we usually do
that with pilot samples and it works
reasonably well across a number of
applications but just Noti noting that
for my regression set
this optimal AAR now depends on these
coari matrices being estimated um
because I'm estimating a vector quantity
and in general that's going to be a
harder estimation problem than
estimating sort of scaler statistics and
might require a high number of pilot
samples so the theoretical optimal a
star may like actually be quite
expensive to
compute um and so since we're not sure
we can get good estimates of this
theoretically optimal AAR we have some
practical uh Alternatives one is to say
okay what if I restrict a to essentially
be a scalar so a is going to be a scalar
Alpha times the identity then the
optimal scalar coefficient has a form
that also may not surprise you it like
has you know kind of similar resemblance
to the optimal a star and so this is
like in in this class of a this is the
best way to choose Alpha star trace of
Gamma 1 two over trace of gamma
22 um or alternatively if you don't even
want to bother estimating these traces
you could just say okay I'm just going
to just as a heris use this Alpha star
that came from mean estimation which you
know is not optimal in any sense but
what we find you know Works reasonably
well
um so this slide essentially summarizes
kind of the three ways that we might
choose that scaling coefficient and now
I'll ask Jazelle if there's any sort of
follow-up questions on on
a or anyone else if anyone has questions
okay glad to hear
it okay so I talked about choosing a um
I haven't really talked about choosing
m&n which is like how to allocate the
samples among say maybe a fixed
computational budget um and I'll just
say that we haven't really done this I'm
saying like we could formulate a
minimization to do this to say like what
are the M andn that are going to
minimize this variance um but it would
be kind of complicated and would also
depend on these estimates that we we we
think in practice might be quite hard to
get so you know just practically maybe
you already have data that's just like
given to you like here's some low
Fidelity data here's some High Fidelity
data so like probably just want to use
all of it um or as a heris use the m&n
that would come from the mfmc paper so
there's like I said an analytical
formula to tell you how many uh samples
to distribute to each model and so
that's what I'm going to do in my
numerical experiments this kind of
puristic thing
all right so just to summarize what we
were able to get out of the theoretical
analysis uh so the first thing is the
multifidelity approach is unbiased with
respect to the distribution of the High
Fidelity data okay so the low Fidelity
data do not have any kind of corrupting
influence and something I want to
emphasize is that this is a kind of
guarantee that's possible in this
multifidelity control variant setting
that is not possible for what I would
think of as more ad hoc approaches some
of which are based on transfer learning
like you don't have that guarantee that
the low Fidelity data are not
corrupting um we also show that if you
have variance reduction of the cxy
estimator this is going to lead to
reduced variance in the coefficient
estimators and therefore reduced
variance in the model predictions and
that's significant because it means that
the lower that the expected square error
of the Learned model is going to be
lower relative to the High Fidelity only
training
process um so we have improvements in
accuracy as
well so before uh the last thing I have
for you are numerical results are there
questions at this
point
okay all right so the first thing I have
is an analytical example in one
dimension because I can plot the models
and kind of show you how the variance
looks so um I just have a uniform random
variable z um High Fidelity function is
an exponential function and the low
Fidelity function is an exponential
function that we've sort of moved around
a little bit so it's a little bit
off uh in this case I pretend that the
High Fidelity model costs one and the
low Fidelity model is a lot cheaper so
one 1,000 times cheaper and they have
quite a good correlation this is like
97% correlated and we're going to fit a
Cordic model so yeah here's the
intercept um and then I've got you know
first second third and fourth order
features um so to ensure like Fair
comparisons um we will say that the the
cost of acquiring data points is going
to be fixed um and so we compare
standard High Fidelity only training so
just filling up that whole budget with
samples from F1 with multi Fidelity uh
training where I use that mfmc model
like sample allocation algorithm to
determine the number of samples and so
this table shows you like how many
samples go to um The High Fidelity model
and the low Fidelity model in the m
Fidelity approach so for a budget of 10
I use 80% of my budget on
um on High Fidelity samples and kind of
the remainder among M there's a reason
that like kind of a a silly reason why
this doesn't all add up to 10 and and
that's something that I could fix but I
just
haven't um but anyway so this is the
number of samples that are being
used uh for different budgets and so I
mean the main idea is like you sacrifice
a few High Fidelity samples in order to
get a lot of low Fidelity
samples okay and so the reason I wanted
to have this analytical example is to
basically show you the how the how these
models vary so
um the black line on this plot is the
best fit CTIC function to the
exponential data you know that's that's
taking exact expectations because we can
because it's a simple example um so
that's sort of the optimum with respect
to the underlying distribution um these
blue lines which are with some
transparency um show you different
realizations of the High Fidelity
trained model and this is with a 100
samples which is like a lot of samples
for a one-dimensional example and so
even with like a 100 samples you see
there's quite a lot of variation in the
fitted quartic functions um for the High
Fidelity only data and then in these
orange Dash lines these are also plotted
with transparency you see a lot narrower
variation like they're much closer to
that beta star okay so we're like just
kind of this is the visual of showing
you like how much more robust the
multifidelity training approach
is um okay so I mean I will walk you
through this kind of a lot okay so now
this is kind of an exploration of the
dependence of the model on the hyper
param hyper parameters so like the
choice of a and the choice of N and M
which depend on those estimates of
Statistics um so
as I mentioned before we have um you
know three different ways to choose that
a like there's the optimal Matrix
coefficient there's like the optimal uh
scalar coefficient and then there's kind
of this heris that comes from like what
you would do if you were estimating the
mean and those three choices of
coefficient depend on estimates of model
statistics so in the left column what
I'm showing you is okay I'm assuming I
have the exact model statistics right so
this is the the case in which like a
star is optimal and that's what you see
the a star has the lowest variance so
this is the trace of the co-variance of
that um of the cxy this is the trace of
the covariance of the estimates and this
is for a fixed Z the variance of the
model predictions and so yeah that
optimal Alpha star coefficient is like
the best you can do if you truly know
the model
statistics um and then these two scalar
things perform kind of similarly when
you know the optimal statistics uh the
exact
statistics and then as I move to the
right um I'm estimating these optimal
statistics as well as the optimal as
well as theistic N&M with 100 Pilot
samples which is you know probably more
than is realistic but um and then 10
pilot samples so that's really quite few
and then you see okay like when you have
just 10 pilot samples okay theoretically
The Matrix coefficient would be optimal
but in fact is suboptimal because you
have poor statistics that you're basing
that that coefficient uh
on um but despite the you know this the
fact that there is some sensitivity to
estimating the statistics um we see
consistently that these multi Fidelity
strategies have lower variance uh in the
predictions than the High Fidelity only
of of the same
cost okay so that was an analytical
example and now I have a pte model
problem this is um a convection
diffusion reaction uh you know model in
a two-dimensional main um
and it's like a one-step chemistry model
and so I have five input parameters
which um this a is not the same as the
Matrix a this is now the arenus uh
reaction a um the activation energy e um
temperature of the inflow and like
initial temperature at the wall and then
Fe is like a fuel oxidizer ratio so
these are five
parameters um the output I want to
predict is the maximum temperature in
the chamber at steady State and um my
High Fidelity data then comes from like
a 2d finite difference simulation where
the cost is 1.9 and that's actually in
seconds so 1.9 seconds and then I have
low Fidelity data that comes from um a
pod dime model and that has a cost of
like 6,000 of a second and in this case
we have a 95% correlation between the
models so this is still pretty highly
correlated okay so here I'm showing you
that for this example so also fitting a
quartic model but to five inputs so
there's like I think like 25 features or
something like that um here the the main
thing to highlight is that when I'm
estimating so like I have like a ton of
samples just stored and so if I've got
high sample estimates like the a star
The Matrix optimal coefficient does do
better as it should in theory but then
when I have to estimate those statistics
those covariance matrices to choose the
a star Alpha star and alpha mean um the
AAR is not on this plot because it's
like 10 to the I don't know like 20 okay
so it's just so bad that you wouldn't
want to do that because it's you just
don't have good estimates for those
covariant
matrices however um the optimal Matrix
uh coefficient Alpha star does
do much better and so that's kind of our
general recommendation in the paper this
is probably the thing to go with in
Practical settings and again like you
know consistently we see that like when
you do that like you get um a lower
variance in the prediction for
multifidelity training than with High
Fidelity training of the same
cost and then here I just want to show
you how that translates to Improvement
in the prediction error or in the
generalization error so um here I've
just you know drawn some samples from
the distribution that are from that are
not seen in training and um this dotted
black line is kind of the optimal
prediction error like um computed uh
optimal computed with a ton of samples
basically it's like a very high sample
reference
um so that's the best we could do and
then with High Fidelity only um I'm
showing you here's kind of the mean over
a bunch of realizations of training and
then I've got like the plus minus one
standard deviation and shaded and that's
over just a bunch of realizations of
training on like different independent
training
sets and uh that's for High Fidelity and
blue uh and then low Fidelity and orange
so here you really see the fact that
we're lowering the variance of those
predictions is significantly lowering
the average uh prediction error or
average generalization error and also
narrowing like kind of how wide that
range is so it's making it robust and
it's making it more accurate it's kind
of the key
takeaway um and that effect is
particularly pronounced um in this
lowbudget regime right so like when when
when data is scarce um that's where
you're really seeing like you know
significant
gains so that brings me kind of to the
end of things so here's a QR code for
the archive paper um
and to just to summarize so we have a
new multifidelity linear regression
method that combines high and low
Fidelity data during model
training um the multifidelity Learned
models are unbiased and they have lower
expected square error than standard
training uh but we do have a lot of open
questions like you know some was I think
Jazelle was asking about like can we
handle different inputs not right now
but we're thinking about it um I also
presented this like entirely for ve uh
for scale predictions like scalar
outputs and there are some interesting
questions about what you would do if you
are predicting Vector
outputs um there's also questions about
like how would you extend this to
nonlinear regression um which we're
working on and have some ideas there's
like actually many ways you could think
about extending it to nonline regression
um as well as additional analytical
questions um in particular like
multifidelity monra Carlo has a lot of
literature on like how to select models
to guarantee that they're going to be
useful um and that's kind of uh
something we could also do here but have
not gotten around to yet so thank you
for um your attention and uh I'm happy
to take questions all right uh thank you
so much for the wonderful talk um we
have a question gel asked how the
correlation between the models affect
the performance what is the minimum
correlations you would recommend between
the models for usable results yeah that
is a great question um and I will say we
have not done that analysis for the
ression setting but a lot of that
analysis has been done for the just the
Monte Carlo setting which is different
okay and so from the Monta Carlo setting
um some of the things we learned it's
you know it's not like that there's a
cut off for the correlation but there's
a cut off for the correlation with
respect to how much the like how high
the cost ratio is so when I was doing
multi montra Carlo for like um just
Unity quantification for um a telescope
model we found we we like used models
with correlation as low as like 38% um
with significant cost reduction it was
like a 10 like you know 10 or sorry 10
to the six like six orders of magnitude
cost reduction and then you can show
that that still leads to variance
reduction so it's really like the worse
the model is the cheaper it has to be to
be useful um but emphasizing that that's
what we've been able to show uh both
numerically and theoretically for
estimating means and that estimating uh
of linear regression does complicate
things a little
bit
Co I have a question so in your second
examples your lower Fidelity model was
the
Pod and I I know some other you know
researcher who's working on the
multifidelity uh settings they also add
the cost of the
training the
podd model I'm guessing you haven't
included that no I haven't right now I'm
just saying like I'm treating those
those models as kind of like oracles
that we have and then the question is
like how would you use the data that
arises from that um but I mean I think
it's a good question I know that you
know there are other people working on
these sort of context aware approaches
where you're kind of like taking into
account how much yeah like how much
effort it takes to just get the low
Fidelity source so so those are
connecting those that body of literature
to this is definitely an area of
interest thank you next question is by
Boris Boris you're you're hereis you I
can also ask you person okay Elizabeth
maybe I I think I probably missed this
um you're optimally assigning these
these uh M's and NS right um I am heris
assigning the M's and n's based on the
optimal Model Management approach for
mean estimation um I briefly touched on
this that like you could try to
formulate um a problem that optimal
assigns the M's and n's for the linear
regression thing but it would depend on
so many statistic estimates that we
don't think we can get well in in
Practical settings that we think that a
heuristic is likely to be uh you know
practically useful okay or practically
useful yeah thank you nice
talk all right the next question is by
Kevin uh thanks for the great talk the
PD example doesn't didn't seem to be a
linear regression problem or maybe I
miss uh yeah I think I was not um maybe
as as clear and explicit about that as I
should have been so um we are fitting a
Cordic model to these five parameters so
like the features X of Z are like you
know like various uh you know constant
and first through fourth order
polinomial terms of these five model uh
five parameters that are being
fit so
yeah oh Al this is still
apply
okay all right um next question is by
Eric Chang earlier I think you mentioned
something about the low Fidelity model
being based on some transer learning
approach possibly breaking the biased
Bist of the estimator could you expand
that yeah yeah let me so let me say that
like I think there's a lot of interest
in multifidelity learning approaches um
and um people I mean there's so many
different ways you could do you could
combine high and low Fidelity uh data so
I've seen things where it's like you
have two neural networks and one trains
on High Fidelity data one trains on low
Fidelity data and then you add them
together somehow or I've seen things
where you like string like you know five
different neural networks together and
some of them map between the high and
low Fidelity data and some of them are
just for the High Fidelity data and some
are just for the low Fidelity data and
I've seen things where it's like onee
old Network or I mean one model and you
just train on the low Fidelity data and
then you just at the end you throw in
the High Fidelity data just to kind of
update things
so there's many ways you could do this
um and the point I was trying to make is
that we're doing it in a way that's
based on the multifidelity control
variant literature which has a lot of
theory including this guarantee of
unbiasedness and that is something I
have not seen for these other approaches
that I was just describing like you know
if you just throw in the High Fidelity
data at the end you don't get that kind
of guarantee of unbiasedness like so I
mean that's not to say that there
couldn't exist a guarantee if you were
careful about it just that I haven't
seen that in that literature and so this
is something that I think is in
advantage of this approach based on
multifidelity control
varats all right thank you next question
is by jackary he asked can you use more
than one low Fidelity
model yes um so this extends very easily
to more than one low Fidelity model and
you just kind of you end up adding like
more terms of the same kind like more
like so you'd have like a second term
with like your F3 and another with your
F4 and then in these variants that I
mentioned the generalized approximate
control variants as well as like the ml
blue estimators they're like sort of
even more General ways of combining
those models um and I I will say they're
they're more General and they get
greater variance reduction under the
assumption that you kind of have those
exact statistics so it's kind of unclear
in practice like how well you do if you
don't have great statistics estimates
but there's lots of ways to to add other
models in
awesome um well let me ask this question
out so so you like the unbiased
model I can see
yeah in some sense that's um Can can it
it can be also viewed as a modeling bias
right I means you you have a mean and
bias and um you know to make it unbiased
you you you go another level and then so
for you you you apply the multi
covariate method on that um so I I see
that like
hierarchical you know modeling approach
you start with the mean and second order
statistic third order fourth order
statistics and so on on and on to to
make the bias model to
unbias
um uh if you maybe you have a different
view on that yeah I that's not how I
would describe it like I would say
um you know this approach is really
about reducing the variance of
estimators of the of the Learned model
parameters and we have an approach um
where we use an unbiased estimator for
the model parameters so that when we
combine them in the multifidelity sense
the multifidelity estimator also remains
unbiased um
if and we're not really using like
higher like the only higher order
statistics that kind of enter into into
the model are the second order
statistics which are just used for
choosing hyperparameters of the method
there's like no third order or fourth
order statistics in this
method yeah if you don't use the estimat
uh but at the end in practical sense
you're using estimates yeah in the
practical sense we are using estimates
of the second order statistics but third
order and fourth order statistics don't
anywhere yeah yeah um so if I rephrase
my question um since we are using the
estimate um there will be another bias
TS which we ignore uh using the
estimates the the guarantees of the
optimality of the variance reduction are
you know sort of approximate guarantees
but in fact the unbiasedness does not
depend on those things so no matter what
like the unbiasness is is there even if
we estimate statistics okay and that's
just from the form of the
estimator okay thank you Elizabeth um is
there any other question wow that's a
punctual 11 a.m. we started punctually
at 10:00 a.m.
and looks like we are ending punct
punctually at 11 a.m. excellent Gold
Star Gold Star yes
all right if there has no uh further
questions let's thank our uh speaker
Elizabeth for the wonderful talk um
Elizabeth you're the great teacher I I I
can see like students uh will love to
take your classes I appreciate that I
hope they
do thank you for having me all right
thank you thank you
Elizabeth all right that ends our uh
seminar today let me start the record
button well I have